This is Jocko podcast number 11 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
And additionally,
today we have our first guest Leif Babin.
Lafe welcome to the show.
Thank you.
Glad to be here with you.
Now to begin this podcast today,
I'm going to start at the end.
I'm going to start at the end of my navy career when I retired from the seal
teams after 20 years.
And this is the speech that I gave on my last day of military service,
my last day in the seal teams,
and about an hour before I walked back to the trade at building
clean.
The last thing is out of my locker.
Loaded them into my car.
Yeah.
And drove away from the seal teams for the last time.
Okay.
With 20 years of memories and experiences and the best times of my life and the
worst times in my life,
all rushing through my mind.
And this is the speech I gave that day.
Okay.
During my last deployment to Iraq in 2006 one of the first things we did was a
series of operations on the eastern side of Ramadi.
In order to execute these operations,
we took a majority of the seals to Camp Corregidor home with the first of the
five oh six band of brothers on the edge of the melodic district of Murmur of
Ramadi.
Okay.
Camp Corregidor was like Ford Apocalypse.
They received mortar fire RPGs and small arms fire daily.
The barracks were an old partially blown out building with sandbags in the
windows,
dirt floors and no air conditioning.
There were no showers.
It was hard living
as far as the fighting.
Okay.
Charlie company from the first of the five Oh six who,
who we were set to work with had suffered almost 40 casualties in the time
they'd been in Ramadi and had gone from a fighting force of 142 just over a
hundred
Charlie company loved having seals with them after the first operation they
conducted with seals.
The company commander told his battalion CEO he wanted seals with him on every
mission to help keep his men alive.
Yeah.
As we continue these initial operations into the melodic district,
there were heavy firefights,
many dead enemy and multiple coalition casualties.
It was intense,
sustained combat.
Many would have considered camp Corregidor and eastern Ramadi to be hell on
earth,
but I knew it was exactly where seals belonged.
We soon completed that first run of missions and had it back to our main camp.
When we got there,
I told one of the platoon commanders,
I wanted him to select guys to form a seven man squad to take back to Camp
Corregidor,
but he told me he didn't want to just pick guys.
He thought that some guys might not want to go back to Corregidor due to the
hard living conditions,
the tough fighting and the high rate of casualties.
That sounded reasonable to me.
So I mustered the whole troop in the planning space.
I explained to them that we were sending a squad to Corregidor permanently
because the army isn't a tough fight and suffering heavy casualties and that as
Americans,
as servicemen and his frogmen,
we cannot sit on the sidelines is that happens.
If there's a fight,
we need to be in it.
I wrote on the Dry Erase Board Camp Corregidor volunteers and I said to this
pack of seals,
if you want to go over to Corregidor,
if you want to volunteer to be in the worst area with the worst living
conditions,
with the hardest fighting and with the highest chances of getting hurt or killed
the,
go ahead and write your name up on that board and then I walked out of the room.
Yeah,
a short while later I came back in and I looked at the list on the board.
It was filled,
in fact,
every single seal to a man had written his name on that board.
Yes.
Every man had volunteered to go forward
into that raging storm
and that is who we are.
That is what we joined the seal teams for to do what no one else can do.
In the worst areas,
in the worst conditions,
we crave the dirt and sweat and fire and blood.
Let there be no doubt it is in our soul.
It is in our nature.
Sure seals can do any job well,
but it is in the belly of the beast where we thrive.
I have seen with my own eyes,
the wholesale slaughter that occurs when seals are unleashed on the enemy as we
were meant to be.
And it is incredible thing.
It is also a thing of strategic impact areas like Ramadi and solder city,
which after years of complete enemy control become pacified soon after the sword
of overwhelming carnage is wielded by the frog men on the high ground.
This is who we are.
Death dealers,
killers,
executioners,
okay.
And in being so saviors,
defenders,
warriors,
now there are those that say we need to change,
evolve,
and mature.
They claim that the nature of war has changed,
that it is more complex and demands a more sensitive approach.